hey so I just saw John wick three that's
a total I actually saw it last week but
it felt weird at like having review a
week early like I like to have it closer
to when the movie comes out but trust me
in my memory of its pretty good I got
back from a critic screening of it and I
literally saw the first two movies right
before I saw the third one which is
weirdly kind of the best way to see
these are good movies to actually watch
back-to-back for countly the Mad Max
movies like they go like they're not
100% linear linear but like they there's
just enough of a connection and they
stand on their own that they're
entertaining I either wait but there are
a lot of fun just to watch back to back
to back so the because I've never talked
about the other films before I'll give
my thoughts real fast uh first film I
really really liked when I saw the
trailer for I remember thinking this is
just another Keanu Reeves when he was
kind of like it kind of looks like he
was on his way out almost are trying to
make a little bit of a comeback but like
everyone said it was great so I saw it
and the right that the actions really
great the he's friggin really great in
it not just the the stunts and the
fighting which is fantastic I can't
believe like how well he can do all that
but his acting was fantastic it and the
plot was so simple I just adored it the
only part where got a little weak to me
was the ending where it feels like it
should have end at one part and then it
just kind of keeps going and gets a
little lost but I used really really
liked it uh second one I also really
liked um but the middle is kind of no no
not not the middle uh second one second
one the beginning is where was kind of
weak cause it kind of felt like I go
where we're doing this again kind of
thing and there's a little bit of a
fake-out like no no we're not doing the
whatever the brother of the bad guy from
the last one wait wait ha ha gotcha and
then it's still kind of looking for its
footing but then like when the actual
plot gets going when the you know server
adrenaline-pumping
story gets going where everyone's kind
of after um it gets good and it gets fun
and it turns out to be a
a surprisingly good follow-up even
though the story gets a lot more
complicated and the frizzen was so
simple so it was very very smart about
that and now we have the third one where
the middle is where it kind of gets lost
and I think that's so funny
it starts off ridiculously strong like I
thought oh my god this is gonna be like
the fury road of like these kind of
martial arts gun movies and then it kind
of levels out and again it gets a little
lost there's even a scene where somebody
says I've never seen a man so lost I'm
just like yeah man that's like the movie
right now but then it kind of comes back
and it ends on you know just more great
acting a good high note for the most
part and but it's definitely like this
is very much like the I think it's
called the el Mariachi trilogy or like
the or like The Evil Dead trilogy where
it's like if the first ones El Mariachi
and Evil Dead and the second ones like
you know desperado and Evil Dead - this
is definitely Once Upon a Time in Mexico
and army of Darkness this is probably
the goofiest and there are a couple of
times where maybe it goes a little too
silly like ice especially in the middle
like I was kind of even asking myself is
this still a John wick movie like
there's scenes where they're like in the
desert
letlet like he's traveling alone in the
desert and trying to find this guy who
who he doesn't even find him like the
guy finds him you know like he has to
like walk in the desert sound like he
gets really weird and Goofy and like
even the guy he finds doesn't really
seem like it was kind of worth the high
for this guy but uh so so it does get a
little lost but it it kind of stops from
getting too goofy by still throwing in
some of those surprises that are both
very harsh but kind of cool too and just
a little silly like I like the gel wick
movies when they're just a little silly
like they're just silly enough the
second one all you know sometimes we go
a little over-the-top too much you know
but but we'll come back
can this one does definitely go over the
top a lot like it is probably the one
that goes the most over the top and at
times it can be a problem but but it
comes back like I said in the third act
it does eventually come back reason the
second one I don't even though his
stunts are amazing his Fighting's
amazing I ideal I feel like he's acting
with was all there I kind of felt like
you know younger Kia no real Ike matrix
Keanu Reeves where it's just like if the
one that we would always make fun of you
know whoa dude you know but this one it
kind of seems like he he comes back into
it like he kind of gets that he has that
grasp of urgency and but also control
that he had the first one but there's
also there's this emotion tool and that
is still there you can tell is there
under like the exterior the tough
exterior that he has which I didn't get
them the second one much I didn't feel
there was much emotion under you know
that Stonewall face they has the whole
time in this one I did so I was glad to
see that back the I am I'm sure you'll
hear this from everyone the action it is
still fantastic like all of them
probably goes on just a hint too long
but but for a lot of people you're not
gonna care it's like that's that's kind
of why you go see these movies you go
for the action you go for it to be
over-the-top but they're still like this
nice harsh grittiness to it that for the
most part it keeps it in check like like
it still seems like okay that this is
kind of funny you know and you're
definitely laughing at scenes but it's
not like a straight-up comedy like I
said with the exception of a few parts
so well so let me get to those few parts
that no spoilers I won't spoil it but
something very important I should tell
you going into this is that there's a
scene that there's quite a few
celebrities in this I think as these
movies get bigger
enough celebrities are like hey I want
to be in this movie or if they just ask
them and I know these movies have clout
you know let's go ahead and most of them
are good choices there's one where as
soon as I saw I went
oh and I'm like well maybe she doesn't
have a very big part there I don't know
if this is intentional they're making it
look like it's gonna be a buddy movie
like oh no these two don't get along
they're gonna have to go on this
adventure together and it's just two
people that they're not a cool duo and
the fun of John wick is it is most of
the time he's you know he's a loner he's
alone you know he's you know the
boogeyman and stuff like that you kind
of don't really if you're gonna have an
equal you really want someone who's
either gonna be that equal or it's gonna
push it to another level or something
like that usually that's the villain the
villains are kind of the equals that
that he fights and they have to prove
themselves and stuff like that so if
you're thinking to yourself this is
gonna be a buddy movie it's not it might
even be a fake-out kind of like the
fake-out they have in the second one
where they make it look like it's the
you know when pierced or mayors gonna be
the big bad guy and then he just
disappears which is great I love it you
get some fun action and then it's like
ha ha gotcha we're not doing that stupid
thing and it might be the same thing
here but again it kind of happens in the
middle so it's a little strange um but
there's really kind of a fun respect for
that to just kind of fooling you just to
fool you but while it's going on maybe
it's just me and I never really got into
this actress I won't say who it is but
uh I just wasn't buying it i never buy
her as a tough person you know like the
badass yeah we're gonna get in a fight
and stuff but I mean she and she's done
good performances and in the past but
yeah I never bought her as the badass uh
but to her credit she does a lot of cool
stuff they have a lava one shot you know
things that they do with Keanu and they
do it with her and it's just like it's
really her and she's doing a lot of
these stunts that you know shit I
couldn't do you know so it's not
something where it's like you know oh
lazy not trying no that's not it at all
looks like she's working her ass off I
just never kind of bought her as this
badass and I don't think she was a good
team up with him
it's but it kind of vanishes you're
there for a little bit and and then she
can she's kind of gone which is weird
but but again it's like you don't quite
know where these movies are going so
while it does get odd it kind of keeps
you guessing and by the time you get to
the end your cowlick yeah all right wow
so fun that's still pretty cool um the
villain in this I mean a couple villains
but the villain in this I've recognized
her from billions and it's interesting
to see what her real voice sounds like
cuz if you see her in billions you know
she has kinda this crackly vice-like
this like it's almost hard to tell you
know a man or a woman the way she died
there you know and then she talks here
it's just a you know a very beautiful
voice oh it's just like oh I didn't know
that was her real voice she does a great
job and I love it when there's people
who are much younger come in and they
act like they're a lot older and they
can pull it off like you look at her you
know she's very young but just like the
the stamina and the dominance she has of
every scene is really really good way
this is an actress I'd love to see go on
to other stuff kind of like the second
film these I think they say these movies
are supposed to take place like in the
span of a week I think I don't quote me
on that
but the idea is that every single time a
movie ends like the next one pretty much
pick up picks up right where the other
one left off and this one probably the
most I mean it is literally 20 minutes
after the last movie which is cool
especially if you watch them together so
it's nice having that long wait you know
like how the next ones coming you know
you you got away for it but it's also
great just going from that directly into
the next one it's almost like it just
keeps the momentum going it keeps the
adrenaline pumping and the again without
giving away too much the ending is
building up like there might be another
one too I work at stop here again it's
one of those
don't know what to think of it it to me
it almost seemed just a little too silly
but I know that's also the fun of these
movies is how how big and crazy can you
get and this definitely get you know it
big and crazy but to me what I like
about these movies is that it just reels
it in where it's like we're not gonna go
we're not gonna go full-on comedy like
it's still gonna be a cool badass action
movie so for for a good chunk of the
movie in the middle I really thought oh
my god
this isn't gonna work like like like
we've lost it we've lost John wick it
just got too big too goofy and now it
doesn't know where it's going and that
is a problem and you do I mean there's
still the cool action everything but
like just something's feeling really
lost but the characters kind of lost too
and it's like if he's gonna be lost he's
gonna be lost in the weirdest way and
then it kind of like I said for the most
part it comes back and like the
motivation is still a little weird and
still a little off especially kind of
let you see what all amounts to but
again that's that's part of the fun is
that it keeps tricking you and it just
kind of does whatever it wants so I
don't know it looks like if there is a
John wick for I feel like I feel like
that's gonna be the one that goes too
far I go bigger I think I'll go crazier
and I don't know I feel like if they go
sillier light like really really bigger
it's just it's gonna be the gremlins to
these movies you know what I mean which
some people would love I mean I feel
like there's a lot of people that love
Once Upon a Time in Mexico and and I
like it fine but it does go really big
and really silly where I feel like you
know serve the el Mariachi and desperado
you know is more my mix that that's more
what I like where it is definitely a
little silly but it's still more of an
emphasis on being really threatening
really intimidating and you feel kind of
the fear and kind of the what could
happen or what character could die away
what character couldn't die so that's
still here
and I think that those are kind of part
of the best elements of it outside of a
course the stunts and the fighting it's
that which is still still fantastic man
the opening of this is like an I mean
the first 15 20 minutes is just some of
the most fun I've had an action movie in
a while like I say really reminded me
kind of a fury road of just that rush of
it just keeps going and going and going
and they just keep upping the style and
the speed and the technique of the
fights going on and they're super silly
but I mean they're still like so much of
it is right there and you know when they
throw a knife that's CG although I do
love this might be the first movie I've
seen where people throw knives and they
don't the sharp end doesn't always hit
though sometimes it's just the hand or
like damn it so they got throw another
one I love that that's a great that's a
great addition so saying you're gonna
get that great rush in the first like 15
20 minutes and it ends on a good rush as
well I think most people know if you're
gonna look for a lot of character a lot
of development that's not exactly what
these movies are about I mean they are
there that I loved the plot of the first
film I think that is so simple but so
effective but what makes these films
great oz like is the world the world
that just constantly reveals more and
more secrets about it and and that's
always great but that's kind of why I
think a John wake for might be like it
might get too silly like this one you
could argue already kind of crossing the
line a little bit but for if you gotta
go even more secrets and even bigger
conspiracies like just everybody in the
world is gonna be an assassin we just
don't know it it'll be like we're a
Revenge of the Sith somebody says a
number or the I was a major ain't
candidate Kimber was called I think
that's it where somebody just says aware
we become killers but I really would not
put it past them if that's for
honestly like like it's just getting so
big and so ridiculous but that's as of
now I think that works out okay uh you
know I think it's kind of like it's just
the right balance for the most part even
though sometimes it really gets off
balance but but it comes back so yeah so
I say check it out I don't know if it's
my favorite the first 20 minutes is
probably my favorite but I'd say I don't
know
the second one's pretty good first one's
great too out these are fun movies I
guess people are gonna debate what's
their favorite one I think because this
one is the most over-the-top it might be
a lot of people's favorites I mean the
fights are still fantastic and
everything you know clips of this are
gonna be played everywhere on the
Internet
when it comes out I people are just
gonna upload these fights and they're
gonna get billions of views because
there are amazing fights but in terms of
isn't my favorite is it still probably
between one and two for me but yeah it's
still damn impressive and it still has
just enough kind of twists and turns and
the secrets of this world and just fun
actors having a great time just going
ridiculously over-the-top and just
having a ball with it and it just
contrasts great off of Reeves with his
stone face
you know I'm I've made fun of Reeves a
lot in the past I really like these kind
of doing this cool comeback and he's
doing it in such this awesome unique way
guy meet people could be like oh it's
like Tom Cruise doing his own stunts you
know he's just trying to do that but I
mean it's something really different cuz
I feel like this is it they both take a
lot of balls and a lot of strength a lot
of focus but this one is just a very
different kind of technique where crews
will go hang off a building or something
like that you know which is like holy
shit that's cool
Ruiz will just plan this crazy a fight
scene that it doesn't have many edits
and you know it's really him and you see
him doing it and they're just two
totally different animals and I think
even if you take the stunts out of it I
feel like some actors that get older
like
they really do mature more and they
bring something else too you know to
their acting and I feel like this is
kind of like he's kind of evolved to a
higher level now which I really like you
know a Kevin Costner did the same thing
I like before I thought he was way too
flat and way too
OneNote and boring but like the past two
or three movies I've seen him in he's
been fantastic so I kind of like seeing
these actors evolve like that even if
it's for something as silly as John wick
I mean just these little martial arts
shoot him up movies but I mean again you
you watch him in that first one I mean
like it works because you get why he's
doing this and even though there's not
much dialogue I mean his acting is great
and it's completely motivated when you
see him just go on this killing spree
and weirdly enough even though the first
one started off very simple I could stop
there as the stories get more and more
complicated it's still kind of works
you're still kind of with him like he's
like I said this movie is probably the
most lost out of them but they kind of
like I said they make him kind of lost
as well and even in the first one he
starts off kind of lost so there's
that's always kind of that weird
connection to all of them is that even
though sometimes he's not always
properly motivated or knows what he's
doing like it seems like that's kind of
the intent almost like he's looking for
something to hold on to some of the grab
on to and have meeting and sometimes
this anger gets the best in sometimes it
doesn't sometimes he's super focused
sometimes he can do something really
stupid and sloppy you know so it's it's
really if they're fun to watch
surprisingly even though he doesn't talk
that much and like I said his goal or
sidequest constantly change I think a
lot of it is him I think seeing him do a
lot of these fight scenes it makes you
now we have an appreciation for the
stunts but it makes you we really kind
of understand the character more cuz
you're telling yourself okay he had to
really train to do all this and be the
best and everything you know what what
does motivate a guy like that you know
what does keep a guy like this going and
I guess
like fury road it's like that the ideas
and stuff are there they're just not
talked about that they're kind of just
showing through his actions and his you
know his confused looks terrific focus
looks and so forth so I mean it is there
it's just not surface level but at the
same time they're just kind of dumb
action flicks too you can go in and and
be for the most part pretty satisfied
like I said I mean sometimes it gets a
little too lost in the middle I've said
that million times already
so I think most people are gonna like
this I think for some it might go too
silly and I get it but I feel like it
really does kind of it has a strong
opening it as a strong ending and I
think are going to be people that like
the middle because it just gets so crazy
but it still comes back to here's a dude
he's gonna kick some ass against some
really colorful fun villains that are
just having a crazy ball a crazy time
doing crazy weird things and it's it's a
lot of fun so if you are feeling lost at
some point just keep in mind it's gonna
in the middle it almost doesn't feel
like John wick but it comes right back
to John wick it's still the the cool
movie you want to go see for some it
might be too weird
for me it reeled it in just enough so
yeah that's about it I will see you next
time take care
you